(rock music)
- It's now time for
tonight's Hashtag Wars.
(cheering)
Braunger.
- I love the smell of
Nathan in the morning.
(laughing)
- Is that from Tuxedo Guys?
- We actually took that from Tuxedo Guys.
- Nice, points.
- Nathan smells real good.
- Mark Normand.
- Here's lookin' at you, kiddie porn.
- Hey!
That would ruin that movie quote.
Points.
Yes, Sara Schaefer.
- I'll be Nickelback.
(laughing)
- But you gotta say it.
You gotta say it like Schwarzenegger.
- I'll be Nickelback.
- Yes, points.
Well done, okay, great.
Thank you, thanks, Terminator.
Mark Normand.
♫ My son will come out tomorrow
- Nice, okay, sure.
Points, points.
Braunger.
- The first rule of Fight Club
is meow meow meow kitty kitty.
(laughing)
- Why?
Why couldn't that have been
the first rule of Fight Club?
Oh, yes, points.
Mark Normand.
- This one time at concentration camp...
(audience groans)
- Is that from the movie German Pie?
(laughs)
Points.
Braunger.
- You had me at big
booty hoes hump wit' it.
(laughing)
- Points.
Sara.
- If you shave it, he will come.
(laughing)
- Uh, Randy.
- Keeping up with the Calrissians.
- Points.
Points.
Jason.
- Han Soloflex.
It just becomes an
infomercial for an hour.
- I like it, points.
All infomercials, yeah, points.
Kyle.
- Kathie Lee and Yoda.
(laughing)
- Randy.
- Qui-Gon Jinn and juice.
I got my mind-
- Yes, oh, love it.
- You ready?
- Nice.
- I got my mind on my Wookiee
and my Wookiee on my mind.
(laughing)
- Points.
Points, Kyle.
- Sklar Wars.
It's Star Wars, but with these guys.
- What?
(cheering)
- I beat 'em to it.
I beat 'em to it.
- Terrible idea.
Terrible idea.
- Yeah, points.
Randy?
- Jay Ewoking, where Jay Leno
(laughing)
approaches an Ewok on the street and tries
to make him look stupid by
asking him a dumb question.
- Kyle.
- Flesh-light-sabers.
(laughing)
- Oh my god,
that's the best thing I've
ever heard of in my life.
- It'd be great.
- Why is that not a thing?
Yes, Rove.
- Mexico (beep).
- Points.
Points.
Baron.
- Sexual Har-Aspen.
(laughing)
- Points.
Cayton Holland.
- Cabo San Lupus.
- Yes.
It's never Lupus.
Points, points.
Rove.
- The Great Barrier Queef.
(laughing)
- Oh, wow.
- Oh, good god.
- I'll give you points, Rove.
- Saudi A Labia.
(laughing)
Very dry.
Very dry though, very dry.
- Baron.
- The South Hole
(laughing)
which is in Taint-Arctica.
- Nice.
- Nikki Glaser.
- Jane Goodfellas.
- Yes, oh, good one.
Points.
- Jim Gaffigan.
- Ape Lincoln.
- Yes, points.
- Nikki.
- Monkey Hard Two: Monkey Har-
- No, I'm not calling on you, Todd.
- I did, I...
- Your button has to light up.
Nikki Glaser.
- Cape Smear.
- Yes (laughing) points.
- Gaffigan.
- Cloudy With a Chance of Thrown Feces.
- Yes.
(laughing)
Points.
Todd.
- Monkey Hard Two: Monkey Harder.
(laughing)
- Ironically, I'm going to give you points
for Monkey Hard Two: Monkey Harder.
Yes, Nikki Glaser.
(applause)
- The Hunt for Red Ass-tober.
- Yes, points.
Jim Gaffigan.
- Auto Focus.
- What?
- Just with monkeys.
(laughing)